I was in Washington DC not long ago for
a uh to help usher in uh Adam Sandler
getting the Mark Twain award
because Mark Twain Adam Sandler
are often mentioned in the same breath
and
um I know it was a really fun uh fun
event a lot of people came out for it
including the ghost of Twain who was not
happy
but that aside uh because I was in DC uh
I reached out to to Jake I let him know
that I was in town and you invited me
over to your home yeah he came over to
the house oh he we had dinner at our
favorite restaurant
uh and then he was
it's actually a it's a it's a very good
restaurant where Wolf Blitzer shows you
to your table
it's called blisters and they just sell
blintzes
but many flavors yeah oh so there's 36
flavors of blints and he shows you to
the table and it's and then it's
embarrassing because he hangs around
until you tip it
but we had uh you guys we were very nice
because you invited me to your home and
uh uh I don't think I told you this but
I got there
I took an Uber over and sometimes Uber's
not precise and I I took an Uber over
from my hotel to where the address that
you gave me for your house and I just
realized I'm like 10 minutes early so
I'm just gonna walk down the street it's
a really nice neighborhood and I'm
walking down the street a little bit and
this
father son come walking up the street
they're walking their dog and they said
uh hey if you're lost
Jake's up that way wow they pointed me
to your house oh my God yeah and I was
like okay I guess it's so clear that I'd
be the only person out here to you know
be seen with is Jake Tapper but anyway
we went out we had a really good time it
was fun and then this is where you and I
are in such symbiosis you said uh
after dinner we went back to your house
and
you said here I want to show you
something and we walk around the
neighborhood and oh yeah you said see
that house right there that's where
Lyndon Johnson lived when he was in the
Senate and then he was like let's go
this way and then he shows me another
house and he's like see that house that
was uh Jacob Hoover's house and then
Clyde and Clyde and I was like this is
fantastic
and of course I know that about you
because in your books and these you're
here to to talk about among many other
things uh you've got a new book all the
demons are here and you're picking up on
these characters he's actually the
children of the two characters you've
been uh you've been uh describing and uh
depicting in your other books but you
have all these great pop culture
references and political references to
the 1950s and 60s and the other books
and I love that stuff I can't get enough
of it you were the one of the first um I
sent a copy of the first book to the
hellfire club which is takes place in 54
and has uh our favorite President uh
President Eisenhower as a as a character
in the book and that was that was really
exciting because it was basically a book
written for me and you yeah no I I
actually fact checked the book I was
like wait a minute wait a minute no no
he had his his heart attack in his
second term uh I saved you from massive
lawsuits uh that was close you know my
life has changed so much Sona has it
yeah let me tell you how I can just get
all this stuff delivered right to my
door I mean if you grew up when I did in
the early 1920s that was unheard of you
know a kid in a cap you had to hey boy
boy you know and you'd have to say yes
sir and you'd have to say you know toss
him a coin go get me that goose in the
window and he'd say yes sir Mr Scrooge
but it was that was was like back then
yeah but now it's not it's so much of
our world digitized an automated why
stick to Old School mailing and shipping
if you mail or ship often let stamps.com
do the hard part for you simply print
Postage and shipping labels right from
your home or office it's ready to go in
minutes no long lines are complicated
setup required it's the easiest so it's
the best yeah postage rates just
increased again hello luckilystamps.com
has the best discounts in the industry
avoid the hassle and get started with
stamps.com today sign up at stamps.com
Conan for a special offer that includes
the four week trial plus free postage
and a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan Jake does a very good
job of and I'm not talking like you're
not in the room but I'm extracting these
two don't read they don't know how to
read I don't read uh well no you read
the novelizations of old Dynasty
episodes okay but uh that sounds pretty
good they're actually very good uh so
you do too yes he writes them I write
them is that is that a real thing no no
that's a million dollar idea well let's
do it let's put it here first it's
really good have you ever those clips
come pop up every now and then like an
old Dynasty oh they're fantastic I don't
Jake not on TV on like Twitter or
whatever yeah they'll be like Alex uh
Carrington is that the end of the
character Alexis Alexis Carrington and I
loved how often how many times one of
them got shoved into a pool they just
decided that was what you do is when
when one woman with uh wearing a dress
with massive shoulder blades and a
massive ring who's an icon uh was pushes
another into a pool a lot of people
and sadly filled with acid you'd hear it
ah and then a skeleton would float to
the top listen we got way off topic what
I was trying to say to you guys is that
uh Jake takes all of these true life
events and he writes uh these novels and
all the demons are here is one of them
and they're really I enjoy them so much
because he has got the characters
bumping into people uh from in the let's
say late 40s early 50s then you're the
this was the second book was in the
second book is the Devil May Dance and
yeah that's the Rat Pack Sinatra is like
a big character in it yeah right and I
love you have members of the Rat Pack
out trying to help solve the crime which
was really it was just really funny to
me that it's just like no I think they
would have been they wouldn't have been
in any shape Dean Martin's like no hold
on a second and then this one's 77 and
like the uh the main character one of
the main characters IS Evil Knievel yes
yeah yeah Evil Knievel is one of them do
you now you weren't alive for because
this takes place in 77 and it takes
place after evil Knievel's jump of
1073. okay but you were one when the
Snake River jumped but boy was I there
yeah
I remember there is footage of a little
boy
wearing a Tweed suit and large glasses
that only an adult would wear I stowed
away in his saddlebags yeah they said
they said he would have made it but he
was unfortunately a pound and a half too
heavy and it was all Tweed
I remember that now you and I yes
you and I would have similar memories
because in this book it takes place uh
in 77 and I remember in 1977 very well
because all these epic things happened
but you do reference the the Snake River
jump which was a couple years earlier uh
and that was such a huge event
I remember as a kid they told us that
they were going to put Evel Knievel in a
rocket you know fire him over a canyon
and we nothing ex you know sparked our
imagination more than that and there was
no I don't think it was broadcast
all I know is that we were visiting my
cousin
in Worcester Mass and we raced out to
the car to listen to what happened and
they said well looks like he didn't make
it and I thought they thought he died
they thought he died because he misses I
don't even think he came close no he did
not you know it was like one of those
Rockets from like uh the Roadrunner in
Wylie Coyote Rockets like really
makeshift and one of the other things
that's so weird about it is that this
was actually considered like an athletic
event like he was on the cover of Sports
illustrator this is not a sport this
wasn't I mean first of all he was barely
a good motorcycle rider to begin with
like he just was like the he was willing
to try yes yes and it's so funny because
in this book
in this book one of your main characters
uh one of the the two children like yeah
and and Ike is working with and and you
make this point that uh he's not even
writing motorcycles and I'm guessing
that you have done the research on this
Ike is complaining because he has to
kind of check out the machinery and
everything and he's working for Evil
Knievel and he has to check out the
machinery and I'm guessing you
researched this that he's riding bikes
you're not even supposed to jump in no
they're not good they're not good for
jumping uh but like Harley's and stuff
no it's really weird but he was just
willing to do it and he built this
you know incredible career that kind of
in 77 is kind of the beginning of the
end of it
um 74 was like his big everybody people
their people our age Conan who who think
that they remember him jumping over the
Grand Canyon but that never happened it
was Snake River and he never made it it
was in a rocket ship not on not on a
motorcycle yeah let's clear that up you
know because we have people no no we get
people texting us all the time yeah evil
himself yeah I interviewed Evel Knievel
on The Late Night show did you really
and all I remember is uh it was not long
before he passed uh and he didn't move
very well and I remember because I think
the thing that every kid knew this is
how big Evil Knievel was we all knew
everything about Evil Knievel I had his
toy the rip core the wind up yeah you
would wind up you would wind up a
motorcycle and you could do jumps with
it and I spent thousands of hours with
my Evil Knievel wind up and it would
crash just like evil wood and fly into
pieces
um but uh Evil Knievel what we all knew
is that he had broken every bone in his
body like 15 times and so this there's a
scene at the beginning of the book
that's based on his real a real event
which is in January 77
uh he literally
um jumped sharks he like then this is
like seven months before Fonz did it
like he like he set up a pool in Chicago
and I think ABC maybe had soured on him
so he was doing it for CBS it was a
special it was going to be uh hosted by
Telly Savalas and Jill St John okay of
course and by the way they were the
original hosts of this podcast
it was
I need a friend with Telly Savalas and
Jill St John and uh and he was good and
it was and everything because this is
post Jaws jaws was you know the huge
best 75 yeah and huge um huge film and
so everything was Jaws and so he came up
with this idea and so much of the stuff
in the book uh having to do with Evil
Knievel was just real from his actual
press conferences from his actual events
and he and he in rehearsals hurt himself
and so the entire the entire special
went on but he wasn't part of it and
yeah because who needs Evil Knievel in
an Evil Knievel special he didn't jump
the shark at all he no he did but he
landed wrong his problem was always the
landing but you mean he heard himself
not the jumping okay in the rehearsal
and then went on to do it no no was
rushed to the hospital with broken bones
what was the special what did they do
all the other like side acts yeah
unfortunately uh that cut away to the
hospital
and the doctor would say we're
extracting a shark's fin
you know what's funny that's in the book
that you talk about and it's a really
funny scene is them trying to get the
Sharks and they don't get good sharks
sharks they're like small sharks that
like they're like little lemon sharks no
way he's he's basically jumping you know
uh koi with larger Dorsal fins and they
had a camera in the pool just in case he
landed in the pool you could see the
shark eat him oh my God and the Sharks
were treated horribly and like a bunch
of them died on their way from Florida
to Chicago where they held this in the
middle of the winter in January stuff
you couldn't get I mean now if you want
to abuse a shark it's much harder
you looked into it oh trust me
I have a beef with those sharks